hi there Steve here again my 90-day
Korean challenge continues I'm
encouraged I feel I'm getting better I'm
understanding a lot more you saw my
interaction with the broad cleaner of
course that didn't really show the
extent to which I have improved my
comprehension when I listen to my
political podcast I have had for so
discussions with Hannah in the office
which we have also recorded and which I
will be showing in the next over the
next week or so and today was Hannah's
last day in the office Monday she's
going back to Korea and we have agreed
that we are going to do a special series
of podcasts just the two of us where
we're going to do the my name is in
Korean and I'm going to help her with
her English she's going to help me with
my Korean we're going to talk about how
we say things in the different languages
how it's different how it's similar what
some of the problems are maybe focus in
on some of those problem areas and we're
going to film it hopefully we'll be able
to do it in quite good quality if we use
our you know smartphones at either end
rather than relying on skype so there's
a few technical issues that we have to
sort out but that's something you can
look forward to starting in the next
little while and in the meantime if you
enjoy my channel please subscribe and
look forward you can look forward to
these Korean videos I apologize if you
don't understand Korean we won't be
doing subtitles but when haven't I speak
to each other in English and Korean we
will probably put subtitles on those so
thanks for listening bye for now